Doron Simon, thank you so much
for being on 20 Minute Leaders.
So gracious of you.
Yeah. Thanks for having me.
So, we know each other
through J-Ventures,
the wonderful early stage
venture capital firm
here in Silicon Valley.
A capitalistic Kibbutz.
You're very recently a venture partner there
an LP in the screening committee.
But besides that,
you have a ton of experience
working with two incredible public
companies on growth and strategy,
Tower Semiconductor and Nice,
and I'd love to spend this episode
talking about just that.
Strategy and growth
and sort of the back scenes of
what drives these companies to success.
I love to share my experiences with that
with that opening.
Incredible.
So, Doron let's just start,
give me a little bit about yourself.
Like where are you from?
What excites you?
How do you even get to do what you did?
So grew up in Israel,
as you can detect from the accent.
I moved here as part
of Tower Semiconductor
when Silicon Valley was
still about silicon and semiconductors.
And this was around 2001.
Did Silicon Valley, was it
actually mainly about chips and silicon?
It was all about chips.
A while back and not too far.
Finally I get it,
only three years later.
Okay.
Amazing.
So, this is after
the standard career army
and then going to study the Technion
and starting some jobs in tech.
And over here, I spend some time
running Tower USA
as President and V.P. Marketing,
and also in between Tower and Nice,
I had a stint as a
consultant for six years
with early stage companies.
I've worked quite a bit with the
go to market strategies
for early stage companies of all types.
Right.
Okay, and just very quickly,
go to market strategy in two words
what does that mean for you?
So, for the early stage stuff,
it's something that many of the companies
have typically a need
or they recognize the need.
But they don't have
a defined product necessarily
or defined how you sell it,
how you package it,
what is the product,
is it a service,
is it something tangible?
So, even if they do have a product,
there is not necessarily a strategy
of how do you get this product
to fulfill this need.
We call it product/market fit
in the textbooks.
But it's a phase where you have to share
what you think with potential customers
and get feedback.
And at least hone on your first version
the minimum viable product.
With software, it's easier.
It's very easy to set up and test.
When you involve hardware
or things that are developed
in the physical world,
it's much tougher.
So, I did a lot of both
more, complicated machines typically.
Okay.
And then, how do you go
from that to growth strategy, M&A
because that's really the next part
of the life cycle of a startup, right?
Yeah.
So the way I look at it,
probably strategy and M&As
are the least discussed realities
in the you call it venture ecosystem.
When you look at it from the
startup side, I'll start with that.
Statistically, most startups
would end their life in,
as part of an M&A
if they are lucky.
Very few actually make it all the way
to an IPO and many fall on the way.
But M&A is a big piece
of the outcome of a startup.
And startups don't gear up
and don't build themself
towards an M&A.
And there is basically
an art to how you do it right.
We'll leave that for later.
From a company
that is a established point of view,
once you've crossed a certain threshold,
and this is typically in the already
multi-million dollar type revenue
so call it 10, 15, 20,
and you start to grow
there's quite a bit of runway,
which you could do by focusing
on what you set up the company to do initially.
Right.
And then starts to be a more strategic approach
of growth that could be coming out
of outside of your core.
How do you accelerate?
How do you address non-core either
features or markets?
How do you respond to market changes?
How do you head risks?
And you get to the more creative side
of business development,
which is either partnerships,
strategic partnerships,
core development,
and eventually M&As.
And in M&As, you're either
being acquired or being the acquirer.
So hold on.
This is really complicated
because what you're
essentially saying is
let's look at a life-cycle
of a startup. We're starting out,
we're running the company,
we're controlling the product,
we're the ones selling it,
and then we reach a point in time
where we are making enough revenue,
you said 10, 15, 20 million,
and we have to start making these
creative decisions of
how do we position ourselves
as key players
and how do we collaborate
and work with potentially
other key players,
either as partnerships,
mergers or acquisitions?
Right. So that is the
interesting phase of mind switch.
We're not alone in this.
Now we're in the big players league
and we can actually work with others
and provide value to others.
Yeah, that's exactly right.
The threshold could vary quite a bit.
So it could happen in 15
it could happen at 150
but in order to cross the billion,
the two companies that I've had
my longest career runs with
are at one and a half billion dollar run rate.
Right.
To get to the billion league,
and this is in sales
not in valuation,
it's not the unicorn billion
it's the actual sales
revenue generating sales.
Per year?
You can get a little bit more
than just your initial momentum.
So you mean that was
a billion and a half yearly revenue?
Yeah.
That's insane.
So, you were essentially helping
lead growth and strategy
in two companies that are public
and they're generating
over a billion dollars in revenue a year.
So, not their market cap is a billion,
but they're generating
a billion in revenue.
Which means you have
a lot of things you can do.
Yeah.
And that's where you come in.
And that's where I come in.
So you generate cash, typically
you get out of the cash starvation mode.
Right.
But you still need to use it wisely
and you need to make sure that
every dollar you invest brings you
much more than that dollar worth
in future returns.
What is that role?
Strategy and growth.
How do even study
for that and prepare for that?
So, there is no official title for it.
Many MBAs would eventually
end up doing pieces of that.
But the role is basically something
that you develop within big corporations.
There's no playbook or school to go to
besides gaining experience.
And essentially every CEO,
or business leader
that is taking a company
to that journey of a
billion dollar company,
comes across the need for that.
How you do it is different.
How you do could vary
from one company to another
in a substantial way.
But you wanna get it right?
...
understanding at the core,
What is your market?
What is your strength?
And in a very realistic assessment,
what you're missing
and what you can get better outside,
which is the first part,
that's what I call the easy part
and when I say easy it's still hardwork.
Yeah.
You need to remember that for every M&A
that happens out there,
there's probably 10, 15 or 20
that you looked at
and you passed for various reasons
before you decide to pull the plug
on the single M&A in a corporate.
And then comes the hard part,
which is the execution.
The integration into a big company.
There's a lot of aspects to consider.
When you integrate, cultural,
work environment,
just different lexicon, different lingo
though you may be in the same market.
A lot of little details that basically
are planned to guarantee that the M&A is
eventually successful and statistically -
Give me give me a couple of those
earned secrets from your experience
in watching M&As
and different deals come about.
Because a lot of them are not successful right.
We hear all the time of these
different acquisitions who turn out,
the technologies didn't integrate,
and the cultures were too different,
or maybe financially it was just didn't make sense.
How can we even start to evaluate
ahead of time whether
an M&A will be successful or not?
So, first statistics in the big world
works against you.
It's similar to startups.
Really? Most M&As fail?
Yeah. Depends whose book you read,
but statistically beyond 50% fail
or don't achieve their original targets.
Wow.
And it does take a lot of discipline
and a lot of planning to do it right.
I believe that also,
you have to consider
the post merger activities
with a lot of what you call EQ,
Emotional IQ,
and treat people in a way that
basically shows them the way
in joining a bigger company
as a career opportunity,
rather the end of the journey.
And a lot of startups
are triggered by the fact that
when they sell out,
it's the end of the journey
as opposed to a start of a new journey,
which is where some of the benefits
could be reaped by the bigger company.
So, unless you buy technology,
if you want to buy a business
and continue to operate and grow it,
you have to keep the team motivated.
You have to get them into your family
and you have to learn how to
leverage each other's strength,
which is a very in a way,
it's a tough process
for every human being.
It's like switching families.
Well, no I mean, and you see the,
a lot of different extremes.
You see some companies
after they perform an acquisition,
they keep the other company
as a separate entity completely,
maintaining their
culture and their DNA.
You see others that are absorbing them
and bring them directly into their offices,
and you know, change your,
from now on you're company X
before you were Y.
Is there now an insight into
how do you do that best?
Or is it a case by case basis really?
To me, and this is coming from
a company that did M&As
at the rate of, let's call it
on average of three or four a year,
there is no playbook per se.
You adjust the case for the company
and it's also a case of the acquirer.
Who is the business owner
that gets to run the acquisition?
And, you know, ideally,
you can buy something and run it
as a standalone company
if everything is perfect.
But it's not the only playbook.
If you're talking about serial acquirers,
people like Cisco, The Times,
Oracle, Salesforce,
they're more operating based on playbooks
and ... history
that is just sheer numbers.
But again, I do feel that when you do
a major acquisition,
when you go into something
that is transformational,
and I've done,
I was involved in something like that
at Nice,
you have to prepare its own playbook.
You can't just open a generic one
and say, "This is my way"
Interesting.
I wanna go a little bit back to growth
because now I'm asking
for some personal tips.
I wish for myself that I'll get
to a position sooner rather than later
that I grow a startup that that has made
a positive impact, has generated revenue,
and now I'm at a position as
in a leadership role where I can now
leverage my new cash flow
to grow the company
and to think more broadly
about how do we become a key player.
What are some of the key challenges or
opportunities for a young entrepreneur
who has never experienced this before?
You have a lot of CEOs that all of a sudden
fall into, they have ...
that generates a lot of revenue
and now they have to make
these strategic decisions.
So, how can I best position myself
when I get to that position,
if I get to that position,
to make the right decision?
So, it is quite, call it, mundane.
When you talk about strategy,
there's a clear way of
working out a strategy.
It starts with analyzing
your strengths and weaknesses
and what are the growth
areas you want to aim.
You talk to customers all the time.
This is something a CEO
knows very well how to do.
And when you talk to customers
and actually listen to them,
not just talk to them,
and a startup CEO by the way
they talk first because
they are used to selling more,
they're educating the market on a new thing.
At a certain point in time,
you have to start to listen
and pick up clues.
What's missing in features?
What's missing in complementary products?
I've seen this company doing a great job
that works together with your
product side by side.
Maybe you want to talk to them
to see if you can cooperate.
You have to be very attentive
to clues like that
in order to develop
that what they call non-organic strategy
and start to address,
you have to know your market.
You have to know the ecosystem.
You have to know
what your competitors are doing.
And the role of that strategy function
or business development function
is to connect all of these inputs
and roll them into one
coherent strategy and a plan.
Okay.
So it's not just going with your
co-founders to the beach
over a weekend on a retreat
and then talking about some startup.
I'm kidding, of course.
But that's what they show
in the movies at least.
Doron, I also want to talk,
because you are coming from Israel.
And one of the things that
a lot of people are are saying,
you know the startup nation is fantastic,
and there's so many great, great companies.
And I've also heard the term
"Exit Nation" roll around a few times.
And it seems like there is
sort of a different mentality,
especially when it comes
to this growth and M&A stage
between a lot of Israeli companies
and companies that are founded
and based in the US.
Do you also see some difference?
Or is there any difference
in mindset in that regard?
I think there is a difference of mindset
and there are many factors
that could be attributed to that,
but first, there is a change.
In the recent years,
you're seeing more companies
break that, call it, one billion dollar
in sales ceiling
and getting to be more common
the things like that
would would happen.
But there is also an ecosystem
that you need to work with
when you do those M&As
and strategic moves
and this is something that
could involve bankers
and investors, access to capital.
And sometimes in
the Israeli ecosystem
it's a very local community
they don't think as much
about that piece of the growth
as the U.S. oriented bankers
and financial ecosystem
around companies.
So, it's not an Israeli mentality thing per se.
You've got a lot of very good
Israeli founders that do it here
in a different way.
But the Israeli ecosystem,
I don't think it is developed yet
enough to address all of these
auxiliary needs.
Okay. So, you're thinking about
in the realm of the Israeli ecosystem
which is, you know,
'cause you need a lot of moving players
to get to a growth mindset
in terms of your ability
to actually grow a company
to that level and get to an M&A.
And it's more about the maturity
of all the players around
not just the founders themselves.
Absolutely. And you've got
very sophisticated set of VCs
which have that, call it, 10 to 12 years
runway mentality.
And somebody needs to take it from there
and this is typically their private equities or bankers,
or other pieces of that ecosystem.
Fascinating. And this is just also,
it sounds like there's so many
moving pieces and it's so much
more complicated than just this
this young and hardy notion of,
let's just create a company
and grow it to be a billion dollars.
No, you actually get to real stuff
that you have to consider
a lot of moving pieces.
And it's not just about the founder.
It's not just about the company.
It's also about your whole market and
where you position it.
Doron, what excites you?
You see so many companies.
You've worked with so many.
What really excites you on the day to day?
So, first every time I see a new founder
with a new idea that kind of resonates with me,
it excites. It excites and gets you energized.
Just because you just identify with
what they're creating or about to create.
Besides that, I love to see a plan
comes through. Okay.
I love to see a plan that you put
four or five or six years ago
and all of a sudden
you look back and say,
"It actually worked.
It was a playbook"
And this is something that is
very very satisfying and exciting.
I'm sure.
And besides that, the deal.
Every time you're involved in a deal
that's an exciting phase.
How many how many exciting deals
would you say you've been
involved with over the years?
I would say, it's probably north of 30.
North of 30 deals?
Yes. Some of them are small.
Some of them are bigger.
But yeah.
Doron, what's small?
What's a small deal?
Small could be an acquisition
that is an acquihire or
technology acquisition
that you do just for a tuck in.
Typically you don't hear about those.
Those are the typical quiet ones.
And some of them could be
much much bigger.
Much more involved.
Much more complicated.
I'm sure. Well, you know.
Doron, just to give context
I mean, the majority of people
in the tech industry,
especially entrepreneurs
and tech executives,
wish they would be a part
of a single great deal
throughout their lives.
So, just listening to you,
I'm getting so much insight and seeing
you've gone through more than 30 deals
whether they're big or small,
I mean, that's just so inspiring.
Doron, we only have just a few minutes left.
But I love to ask this last question to everybody.
And I'd love to know three words
that you would best use to describe yourself?
I'm especially curious,
I hear from people of all industries.
So, what are your three words?
Three words.
One for sure would be foresight,
Foresight. What does that mean? Explain.
Being able to look ahead.
Okay.
Behind the curve.
So, foresight, I would say you have to have
tenacity to last in this industry.
Do what I do.
And the underrated one
of all is team player.
I think that's critical
to be a team player.
You mentioned right before we started
the call that one of the things
that you are very proud of is that
a lot of the great successes you've been
a part of it's not necessarily
that you had to be, you know,
the founder or the leader.
But you sometimes you were the guy
in the back behind the scenes
that was really thinking things through
and allowing for the great deals to happen.
But at the end, you're a team player.
That's how you identify yourself,
which I think is beautiful.
Yeah. A lot of
business development guys
are in the shadows
for many, many reasons.
But I have met over my career
some great ones, and
they're all able to foresee and execute.
I love it.
Doron, thank you so much for the time.
Thank you for the inspiration.
And I'm just going to have to see you
around in the J-Ventures meetings.
I can't wait to see us
face to face again.
Thank you. Take care.